so this is what I've done you notice
here that I had to add a new div with a
container class this makes sure that the
margins on the side of the screen look
good then inside of the container we
have our row and then finally the
columns inside the row scrolling down we
can see that each row has a total of
twelve columns so for instance this row
with featured work has column medium 12
while the row below featured work
contains two columns each one of class
column medium six notice how we have
multiple rows on the page for instance
we have a row here for featured work and
inside the row we have column medium
12th because featured work takes up the
entire width of the screen however in
the row that contains our two samples of
work we have two columns each of size 6
6 plus 6 is 12 so these two take up the
entire row coming back to our question
we did need to add a container div
outside of our rows so that one is true
we didn't need to add any new divs to
organize columns and rows that was
already done for us inside of our rows
we did need to add new divs with columns
to organize our content so this last one
is also true if you want to see the full
solution check the link in the
instructors notes